You ever see those a swamp people shows with them.
Boats filled with fucking alligators.
I don't even think they eating those man.
I think most of those,
they're just taking the skins off of them and selling it for the leather.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what's really valuable.
Yeah.
Dude,
I have,
I have no,
no adventure in May.
I watch you posting videos of you hunting and killing things and then eating it.
It's like if you just go back to your,
your Instagram three days in a row,
it's like I could watch like a,
an animal alive to being on your plate and it's fucking,
I mean more power to you,
dude.
The whole thing.
Um,
I watch it in all because I could never,
I could never kill something even in a,
even I don't even have to lead.
Could kill something.
Listen to me.
You could kill something and you definitely could if you wanted to feed your
son,
there's no doubt in my mind.
If you had a gun and there was a deer and you are hungry,
starving,
yes.
You don't even have to be starving.
He just have to have not the best prospects are manifesting right now.
It's like 11:00 AM I'll fuck him.
What does this Jamie,
46 grams of protein and alligator is that a pound?
3.3 ounces.
Holy Shit.
Three ounces of alligator,
46 grams of protein.
You gainers out there.
Well of course it's a goddamn murderous dinosaur.
It's got no fat on it.
It's just muscle and skin.
They're monsters,
man.
Terrifying that story about like they'll eat like,
uh,
that's the other thing about becoming a father that people don't tell you
everything makes you terrified.
Oh yeah.
So you know the,
I'm supposed to put my kid to Disney in July and there was a story with the
alligator who grabbed the little kid and dragged them into the uh,
on the property of Disney.
Yup.
Or the father.
Just watch this kid get eaten.
Dude,
Florida,
there's too many alligators.
They can't keep track of them.
So if you have a body of water and you're not standing there 24,
seven,
when the fucking spotlight and a rifle,
those cops can sneak into that water.
That's,
that's some real shit,
man.
They'll sneak into that water.
They'll cross that grass.
You don't know they're there.
They climb that water.
You don't know they're there and they'll be underwater for an hour or two hours
and they'll pop the little head up.
They see that little kid now,
God damn,
I'm hungry.
That kids too close to the water and let's just grab them.
They don't have any qualms about that.
They don't know what the fuck you are.
They don't care what you are.
They have a brain the size of a goddamn walnut and they'd been alive in that
form for who knows how many fucking millions of years and they just kill,
kill the take.
They can go without food for a year,
man,
really 95 alligators removed from Disney property in Orlando.
Toddler killed 95 that was just like in that last year.
This was two years ago.
They're too tiny.
Five up to 400 alligators through April.
Like it's a project,
like they're building a fucking bridge.